hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar titled
savor the flavor
keeping meat products safe with a
veterinary drug screening comprehensive
workflow solution
i am christy jewell of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by agilent
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone
that today's event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
like at any time you like during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send please address each
question
to each specific speaker we will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
i would now like to present today's
speakers
dr patrick patoon product manager of
triple
quadruple lcms and cg joseph
solution scientist both of agilent
technologies
for complete biographies on our speakers
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen gentlemen
welcome
you may now begin your presentation
hello everyone and thank you for
attending this talk is called savor the
flavor
keeping meat products safe with a vet
drug screening workflow solution
accompanying me in this talk is my
colleague cj joseph
who is an application solution scientist
and we're here to talk about routine
veterinary drug analysis
and to promote our solution for the
challenges faced
within this field
to set the stage for this topic the
first question to ask
are what are veterinary drugs and why do
we want to monitor veterinary drugs and
food
first off veterinary drugs are
extensively and commonly used
to improve the growth and health
outcomes of livestock farm animals
this prevents the transfer of parasites
and other diseases
used to treat physical ailments like
cuts scrapes
and bruises or to even increase growth
or
secondary product yield
these drugs elicit some kind of
physiological response
many of these vet drugs are the same
medications used to treat humans
thus improper use can result in some
serious adverse
effects acute immediately
or chronic built up over time
thankfully many governing bodies require
the monitoring
and reporting of residue levels for the
various
primary and secondary food products from
these animals
some examples of vet drug treatments are
for the treatment
or prophylaxis of parasites and cellular
diseases
anti-helminthic drugs are used to treat
parasitic worms
like the deworming medication you give
to your household cat or dog
or cassidyostats which are used to treat
cocidiodosis which is an infection by
some kind of parasitic prokaryote
and can be highly infectious and
damaging to a livestock herd
additionally some vet drugs are not vet
drugs at all
as they are the standard medications
used to treat humans
these can be common and sad painkillers
like paracetamol
ibuprofen aspirin or in humans
prescription
grade corticosteroids and lastly
sedatives or tranquilizers used to calm
the animal down
such as in the case of giving birth or
during animal transport
some compound names you may have heard
of are
alprazolam otherwise known as xanax
diazepam
valium or ketamine regardless
these vet drugs were made to elicit some
kind of physiological response
and when transferred to the consumer can
cause very adverse reactions
as mentioned earlier the presence of vet
drugs is highly regulated
because effects can easily be
transferred to the consumer
however various regulatory bodies set
their own
maximum residue limit or mrl guidelines
that differ animal to animal country by
country or region by region
one of the stricter examples are
regulations by the eu
which has defined a forbidden compounds
list
in food which may or may not be adopted
by other parts of the world and are
subject to evaluation
by those other countries or region's own
experts
in other words the regulatory landscape
for vet drugs
is highly complex because various drug
classes are active
at various physiological levels and what
is acceptable
to one country may be rejected by
another
the term maximum residue limit or mrl
is applied to the analysis of all foods
and not limited to meat or dairy
in the case of screening for pesticide
residues in fruits and vegetables
however
there are generally two mrl targets to
consider
zero residue meaning nothing is
allowed to be detected or a general
benchmark of 10 ppb
regardless of the plant matrix
vet drugs on the other hand are
regulated to be zero residue
or of various mrl levels depending on
the animal
chicken beef pork shrimp etc or the
matrix type
dairy muscle fat organ
and this is because as mentioned before
the vet drug activity
and concentration will depend on class
so a simple 10 ppb mrl such as that used
in pesticide
analysis in fruits and vegetables may
not be feasible
it is entirely possible that a vet drug
exhibits some kind of effect
at the 10 pdb level so a lower mrl value
may need to be defined
since there are so many regulations and
guidelines
establishing mrls for vet drugs
mrl varies based on different region and
different matrices
this makes the comparison to pesticides
highly complex
for vet drug analysis some countries
utilize the 10
ppb pesticide guideline but because vet
drugs have different physiological
activity levels
they vary region by region
based on the points made in the previous
slide
you can get a sense of the complexity
faced when monitoring for vet drugs
maximum residue limits vary depending on
geographic region the type of matrix or
the classes of compounds
people interested in monitoring vet
drugs need a robust set of
instrumentation
and a robust workflow but also able to
reach the sensitivity limits required
from these regulations
as you can imagine grinding up some
animal meat or diluting some
egg or milk can easily soil the
instrument
and the steps to remedy this can be
extremely time consuming or challenging
lastly you can have the best sample
extraction materials or the best
laboratory
instrument in the world but still face
challenges
especially in the case of having the
skill to develop
efficient sample preparation or
instrument workflows
and hopefully by the end of this talk
we've demonstrated that we've taken many
of these
considerations in mind to develop an
easy to use
streamlined fitter near drug workflow
that is sensitive enough
to reach the most rigorous regulatory
limits in a consistent
and reliable manner
a major problem faced in the field of
vet drug analysis are that these drugs
are highly heterogeneous
in regards to chemical structure or mode
of action
oftentimes these workflows are split
logically in some way
that is convenient for the lab for
example
the analysis of a specific chemical
class may need specific chemistry
specific sample prep to produce multiple
extractions from a single sample
or another way to approach this is to
run multiple chromatography
mass spectrometry methods from a single
extraction
either way this is a major problem for
the lab because there may be redundant
steps involved
being repeated multiple times if we just
consider the examples on the side
for example the detection of antibiotics
anti-helmanifics
and nsaids are done separately it will
take about one hour per analysis for a
single sample
this essentially means that resources
are consumed for each analysis
and is highly throughput limited by time
our solution that we're promoting today
is a multi-residue approach
start to finish otherwise known as end
to end
meaning that we want to consolidate the
multiple analysis
of a sample to a single analysis that
can detect and quantify
the various compound classes
simultaneously
based on the example shown previously
this will take in at least
60 minute instrumental analysis to
something that takes about 15 minutes
keeping in mind that this does not
include the sample preparation steps
which further lengthen the workflow and
lastly
things to think about how to actually do
this is how do you streamline the
process so it's simple
efficient and scalable so that we can be
providing the lab scientists something
of value
compared to if they develop the workflow
completely on their own
so as i transfer my presentation over to
cg the applications in workflow
scientists
i just want to point out the challenges
to developing a streamlined multi-class
workflow method
for our primary considerations we aim to
develop a generic sample preparation
method
that can be applied to many sample
matrices beef chicken pork etc
and encompass the wide array of chemical
classes within the scope
of the veterinary drug umbrella to
complement the generic sample prep
must be a generic instrument analysis
method
maximizing the full potential of the
chromatography and mass spectrometry
system
the method must have high sensitivity to
meet the regulatory targets
while also eliminating false positives
or false negatives
then to ensure that this workflow is
truly valuable for its users
we have these secondary considerations
like
robust for day-to-day operations that
the workflow is cost effective by
maximizing the utility of each component
the consumables instrument reagents etc
and lastly that it is scalable
to address a large volume of samples
so now that i've laid out the challenges
i would like to transfer
over to scientist cg joseph for talking
about how
he and his team have addressed many of
these challenges
in a veterinary drug workflow
thank you patrick and hello everyone
before going to the technical updates
let me share the instrument
configuration and some of the key
components in the flow path
we used a 1290 infinity to lc system
coupled with agilent triple quadrupole
and agilent consumables to perform the
workflow
a high speed binary pump a multi sampler
and a multi-column thermostats are the
individual modules of the lc stack
a high speed binary pump is an ideal
friend end of the high speed lcms
applications
the multi sampler is a high capacity
injector module
enables to handle the increased number
of sample load
and best suitable for precise injections
the needle assembly was washed with
three solvents
using the multi-wash feature of the
module and this minimized the carryover
issues
inline filter included in the
multi-sampler floor path helped
to increase the column life while
handling complex matrices
the multi-column thermostat connected
with infinite lab poroshell 120c 18
column
help to perform the fast gradient and
ensured day-to-day reproducibility
the workflow performance was verified
using two models of asylum triple quad
systems
6470b and 6195c
these robust triple quad systems
together with mass under software
helped for reliable and sensitive target
detection using
dmrm acquisition mode
the agilent jet stream esi source and
work shield features
help to collect the uninterrupted data
from a wide range of matrices
and increased lab productivity
agilent also provides a set of
consumables which ensures
the day-to-day reproducibility of the
workflow solution
the captiva em lipid cartridges included
in the consumable list
is very selective and efficient for lip
removal
without any analytic loss
the bundled consumables ensures the
confidence in sample
reproducibility
the overall workflow summary is shown in
this slide
2 gram sample in a 50 ml polypropylene
tube
is a start point of sample crop
webdruck standards were spiked to this 2
gram sample to get
pre-spiked qc samples
in this workflow we used three different
concentrations of qc samples
to evaluate recovery
the qc sample concentrations are spread
across a wide calibration range
replicates of qc samples were also
prepared to verify
the recovery repeatability and
reproducibility parameters
the unspiked sample was used as a blank
matrix
both spiked and unspiked sample tubes
will go through
the same sampler protocol which is a
liquid liquid extraction
followed by captiva yuma lipid cleanup
the three different concentrations of
matrix spiked extracts
will be further diluted to prepare ready
to inject
low mid and high qc sample wires
the unspiked sample tube will eventually
result in a blank matrix extract
and this blank matrix extract will be
used to prepare
matrix matched calibration levels and
matrix blank vials for lcms analysis
now let's go through the various steps
involved in sample protocol
the workflow is verified for chicken
beef and pork mussel materials
the first step is to weigh finely means
2 gram muscle sample into a 50 ml
polypropylene tube
for simplicity i will guide through the
various sample prop steps
using one each of spiked and unspiked
sample tubes
spike the veterinary drug standards to
one of the tube
for matrix spiked qc
vertex the tube for 30 seconds to mix
the standard well with the sample
then wait for 20 minutes to infiltrate
the standard
into the sample matrix
keep the second tube as unspiked for
matrix blank
next is a two-step liquid liquid
extraction
this includes the first extraction with
aqueous buffer
followed by extraction using acidified
organic solvent
a mechanical shaker is used to automate
the extraction procedure
followed by a centrifugation step to
settle the sediments and get a clear
layer of the extract
next is captiva cleanup captiva emma
lipid 3ml cartridges
together with positive pressure
manifolds are used to clean up the
extract
performing captiva cleanup is very easy
and we don't have to do
any traditional sp steps such as
reconditioning
conditioning washing extra
the captiva cartridges are designed for
gravity elution
and allows a hands-free operation once
the sample is loaded onto the captiva
first pass the extract through the
captiva cartridge and during this step
lipids are trapped in the solvent while
target analytes
are passed through the cartridges then
perform a second illusion using 90
percent acetone nitrile
to maximize the target recovery
hypogenized element from the spike
sample is used to make the final ready
to inject
qc samples the blank matrix extract
from unspiked sample is used to prepare
ready to inject matrix blank while and
post spike
calibration levels this slide summarizes
the performance criteria we used to
demonstrate
the success of the newly developed
webtrack solution
we are very confident in the overall
performance of the wetlax solution
because of the extensive tests we
performed
while developing and verifying the
analytical protocol
the targets are identified from aoc
guideline and eu
us regulations and verified the
methodology by following
standard method performance guidelines
from aoc
the test includes sensitivity which
includes lod and low q
and linearity study using matrix matched
calibration levels the recovery
evaluation was performed using
three matrix byte qc samples also
intraday and in the day recovery
analysis using matrix spike qc samples
next several slides we will show you the
results generated with other lens 6 for
70 beats required
using chicken muscle and conclude the
presentation with a comparison study
using beef and pork muscle
is to showcase the mrm overlay of 210
veterinary drugs
force spiked at 2.5 microgram per liter
in the blank chicken matrix the
symmetric sharp peak shapes
demonstrates the efficient
chromatographic separation of targets
within the 13 minutes elusion time
two or three target specific mrm
transitions are included
for each compound and the mrm
transitions are optimized using
mass under mrm optimizer the insert plot
is a zoom in view of normalized peaks
corresponding to six early eluting
targets the sensitivity is always a high
demand
analytical measure limit of detection
lod is one of the important criteria and
lod data of all 210 targets are
summarized in this bar chart lod of all
targets are less than 10 ppv
you can see from the chart lod of
majority of the targets are less than 1
ppb
in addition to the sensitivity bar chart
the slide included
two overlay mrm tracers as an example
data
the first is overlapped mrm duplicate
injections of sarafloxacin wet drug
at 0.25 ppv
signal to noise is important criterion
to establish
a lod but here in addition to signal to
noise
we have also included filters like
closeness of ion ratio
increased area compared to blank matrix
area rst from triplicate injections
to our sine 0.25 ppb as
lod for sarafloxacin
the right side phrase is an overlay of
mrm
for the same target at 0.5 ppb
here also we verified all these
performance characteristics of the peak
to label as limit of quantitation hello
cube
this slide summarizes the highlights of
dynamic mr mod
agilent triple quad system enables to
perform sensitive detection of hundreds
of targets simultaneously
the dmr mode allows the user to input
a fixed cycle time and the software
automatically adjusts the mrm dwell time
for a specific time period flexibility
to add
hundreds of mrms within a method but
allows the instrument to do
the active mr monitoring at the relevant
time
changing the cycle time will not
significantly compromise the quality of
mrm data
customers can still add more mrms to the
existing method
good linearity is a basic need for any
quantitation based analysis approach
a good sample protocol means consistent
reproducibility of linearity
across different matrices as a part of
extensive
inter-batch studies many calibration
curves are generated for all targets
an overlay of linearity curves for
classic model
is shown in the slide as an example
the calibration curves are using matrix
matched spike samples from
loq which is 0.25 ppb to
100 ppb the overlay shows that
all calibration curves have consistent r
square values
and slopes please note this all done in
different batches
either different batches of chicken
mussel or beef or pork mussel
this illustrates the efficient lipid
removal of
captiva emr cartridges regardless of
fat distribution across food mattresses
the instrument precision and accuracy
results are also excellent
the data shown here is rt precision and
accuracy results generated using
matrix matched calibration levels in
chicken matrix
the left chart is of rt precision and
rtrsd values are way lower than 0.5
percent
the rt precision rsd results confirm the
reproducibility of
lc elusion profile and column
performance
the average accuracy values were
calculated for each
post pipe calibration levels and the
values of all targets
were within the limit of 70 to 120
percentage
the example data shown here at the right
side is for
10 ppb level recovery is another
criteria
for method performance evaluation more
than 97
percent of targets demonstrated good
recovery
from 60 to 120 percentage in chicken
matrix
this is an excellent result if we
consider a single
sample prep for multi-class vet flux
recovery was calculated using target
response in matrix spiked qcs
and measure response using matrix
matched
calibration curve equations
the slide shows an mrm chromatogram
overlay of the three targets
trimethoprim oxybendazole and phabanthal
the post extraction sample traces in
black
and the pre-extraction sample trace in
blue
at a concentration corresponding to 1
microgram per kilogram in chicken
the response counts comparison between
post
extraction and free extraction qc
samples indicates
a good recovery approximately hundred
percent for all these three targets
while developing and verifying the
solution performance we need extensive
intra-day recovery repeatability and
inter-day recovery reproducibility
to ensure the reliable day-to-day
operation of the solution
in the day reproducibility study was
performed with
different sample loads different
analysts different instruments
different laboratory environments
performed on different dates
the plot at right side shows in the day
recovery reproducibility results
generated using chicken matrix
all results of all the targets falls
within aoc limit of
32 percent rsd also please note
in that the recovery reproducibility of
more than 91 percent of the targets
are within a tight rst of 15 percent
the comprehensive veterinary drug dmrm
solution supports
the analysis of beef and pork muscles
also
the data shows here a 10 microgram per
kilogram
middle qc sample recovery of beef and
pork
mussel the beef data is on the left side
and the pork data is on the right side
the recovery results are in good
agreement with bread of chicken matrix
more than 97 of the targets were within
the acceptable range of
60 to 120 in chicken matrix
while more than 94 percent of targets
were within the acceptable
range of 60 to 120 percent in beef and
pork muscle this confirms
the applicability of the workflow
solution in other matrices also
we did evaluate the matrix effects as
well
like any other level protocol veterinary
drug analysis in food matrices
is also very challenging not all targets
are well behaving
some are giving real trouble in matrix
we did a comparison between neet
standards
with matrix matched spikes
to evaluate the matrix effects
during all three matrices more than 93
percent targets
well behaved and not having significant
ion suppression four percent of the
targets demonstrate some average level
of
iron suppression while three percent
of targets experience significant ion
suppression
on the right side we are showing three
example situations
the blue is neat standard green trace is
post spike and the red trace is
pre-spike
the first example is with trimethoprim
where all traces are the same intensity
we can say that the target thy method
did not exhibit any ion suppression
and the recovery results are very good
in this case while the case of sulphur
so medium
observed high ion suppression but
recovery results are satisfactory
example situation is for the target
erythromycin
this target also experienced high ion
suppression
and recovery results are also suffering
for this target
details of all these data are included
in the agilent application node
5994-1932 en
a dmr database is also included in the
agilent comprehensive veterinary
workflow solution the database includes
details of all tooth and targets and all
the relevant ms details
we can filter the targets in various
ways like
regulation chemical classes or class
numbers
the database can be used to customize
accusation methods
for a set of interested targets in a
convenient way
as per local regulatory requirements or
laboratory needs
this slide summarizes the technical
results of workflow the results
summarized in 10 bullet points
the captiva emr lipid based sample prep
approach
is like a hands-free sample prep it can
parallelly process up to 48 samples
in less than 30 minutes
the column included in the workflow
solution helped to develop
faster gradient for multi-class
sensitive lcms analysis
the workflow covers 210 targets from 28
different chemical classes
and these targets are listed in aoc eu
and u.s regulations or guidelines
the lod of all targets are ranging from
0.1 to 10 ppv and the sensitivity meets
the mrl screening requirements
precision and accuracy of all the
targets were also evaluated
and is within the acceptable limits
the linearity of all targets evaluated
using matrix matched
calibration levels from loq to 100 ppb
and r square values are above 0.99
the recovery analysis was also performed
using three
matrix piped qc samples intraday
recovery repeatability
and in the day recovery reproducibility
were also evaluated
to confirm method robustness
the mrm database included in the
workflow solution helps
to customize the methods based on local
laboratory needs
and regulatory requirements
applicability verified for three
matrices
like chicken beef and pork workflow
performance verified using
two models of asylum triple quad 6470b
and 6495c the solution
also includes system suitability
standard mix for continuous monitoring
of the solution
the standard mix is a cocktail of 25
vertex standards
and covers 10 different chemical classes
and favoring both positive and negative
mode ionization
a typical resulting dmrm chromatogram of
the test mix is shown here
we can use this standard mix as a qc
sample for routine monitoring of the
solution
to ensure confident day-to-day operation
besides the system's suitability
statistics can
also use to perform any troubleshooting
or performance checking of any tests
like linearity carrier
inter day repeatability etc a customized
master report template
included in the solution helps to
quickly summarize
the performance evaluation and quality
check report
with the system suitability test mix
both the test mix and the custom port
helps the laboratory to implement
in-house
lab operating procedures to monitor the
performance of the workflow
and thus prevent any unplanned downtime
thank you everyone and now patrick will
guide through remaining slides
and will share few other exciting
product related information
patrick over to you thanks cg
for the great technical details
described moving on to the actual
workflow product
we've managed to package it into a kit
which includes the consumables
columns method parameters reporting
templates and other supporting material
if you're interested you can check out
the fully public and detailed
application note
for all the information provided so
you can develop methods on your own
however
the nice thing about the kit product
that we are promoting
is that it is a complete package of
everything that is needed for
successful execution of this particular
workflow
in regards to the regulatory environment
we cover
at least 200 analytes which fall within
the regulatory jurisdiction
of the various organizations here with
the distribution of chemical coverage
shown in the pie
chart we've chosen these regulatory
organizations
because they've provided the most
rigorous mrl guidance
that were built into our methods
again there are a variety of technical
references you can refer to
if you're interested and would like more
information
otherwise feel free to reach out to your
local agilent sales rep or go through
our website
and have someone contact you and we can
get you the pertinent material as soon
as possible
just to give a broad overview of
agilent's triple quadrupole lcms
portfolio
we only have three instruments serving
different aspects
of the routine workflow in regards
to the comprehensive veterinary drug
solution
it is a quite stressful method so we
take advantage of the research enabled
aspects
of the 6470 and the 6495 lctq
in terms of product launches this june
2020
we have a new revision of the 6470
which we refer to as the 6470b
adding many of the newer functionalities
for multivo
and the 6495c such as vacshield
at this point all of agilent's lcms
triple quadruple instrumentation
are vac shield enabled to maximize the
instrument uptime for routine
applications
to close with some final notes
a comprehensive workflow was developed
to analyze multiple classes
of veterinary drugs simultaneously
this workflow covers at least 200
analytes
and is fully validated on the 6470b
6470a and the 6495c
lcms triple quadrupole this multi-class
workflow
was done to consolidate several single
class methods
the workflow described was developed
into an
actual comprehensive end-to-end solution
product
that was fully validated cross lab and
cross
instrument for the models described
the workflow solution was designed to be
end-to-end
covering sample prep instrument analysis
data analysis
and reporting for users of this kit
to successfully execute veterinary drug
analysis
in a scalable manner lastly
this workflow kit can be customized to
local laboratory and regulatory
requirements
to suit our users needs
so with that feel free to reach out by
consulting your local agilent
representative
visit our website or feel free to search
online for the reference material we've
described
and with that i'd like to open the floor
to any questions or comments
that we can try to address thank you
very much
thank you patrick and thank you cj for
your informative presentation
we will now start our q a portion of the
webinar now to our audience again if you
have any questions you would like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
ask a question box on the left
and click send now let's get started
okay gentlemen let's start with our
first question here
could you please elaborate on what was
meant by
method customization
hello can you hear me yes
thank you for the question yeah what we
meant by
method customization is like um even
though we have
a comprehensive method addressing 210
targets
maybe a user
interested target may be different they
may be focused only on targets specific
to
chicken or specific to beef or maybe
specific to
eu regulations so what
we meant by method customization is like
we are
giving a database the mrm database
with that database we can easily
customize
a method mrm method
with with the targets interesting to
the local laboratory need or
regulatory requirements so it's very
easy to search targets from this 210
list
and create a subset method very easily
with few clicks
thank you thank you cj
now our next question is the kit
instrument specific
and can it be used in other ms
instruments
dt or patrick
um can you please repeat the question
one more time please thank you
yeah absolutely is the kit instrument
specific
and can it be used in other ms
instruments
yes um so right now the verified
verification is for two models um
[Music]
of course we don't have data with other
models but it is
it can be adopted to other models yeah
thank you thank you i just want
questions
yeah yeah i just want to add that the
the results presented
and the kit is
kind of instrument specific in that the
methods that we
show and presented um are
what is successfully done with the two
models um if
you if you attempt to try this on
another insurance model that we didn't
present for
we can't really guarantee your success
thank you patrick now can this workflow
be done on other
matrices besides beef chicken or pork
mussel
okay yeah so um as we presented this
the data is for three matrices which is
chicken
beef and pork we have verified the
workflow for
these three matrices um it can be the
method can be
extended for other materials but right
now it's not
verified but the protocol
is definitely can be extended for other
materials
okay one more thing is like we are in
the process of
extending extending this workflow for
other matrices and
we will release the the data with
other matrices in up north in the near
future
thank you cg now gentlemen can you share
what are the advantages
of captiva emr lipid extraction if
compared with
dsp ah okay
um captiva uh as i mentioned during my
presentation is
very easy to use it's like almost like a
hands-free operation
uh after once we load the ex the
elements
the extracts to the cartridge bed and
it's designed for gravity illusion and
all the lipids
will will stick to
the bed and the analytes will freely
pass through the bed and
it's easy to recover that way and um
the cap the asylum ppm is a kind of we
can process
48 samples simultaneously in less than
30 minutes so it's all very
user friendly compared to the
conventional dsp
technique we don't have to do any of the
steps like pre-conditioning conditioning
or washing kind of steps
in the captiva cleanup procedure
thank you cg now gentlemen i'd like to
go with this question it's come in a few
times
could you elaborate on the application
service
yeah the application service is what
it's another component to the overall
package of this workflow
and what it is is that the you
can get consultation service that
helps you successfully execute this
workflow
and navigate through any bumps or issues
along the way
so this is essentially as you
practice this workflow and incorporate
this into the lab you have the watchful
eye
of a professional agilent applications
chemist
just so that you can catch any pitfalls
and help you through the software help
you customize your reporting
or anything like that just to make sure
that your transition
you know from a conventional workflow to
something like this is very very smooth
thank you patrick and gentlemen we have
time for a few more questions but i do
want to remind our audience that any
questions we're unable to answer today
due to time
they will be addressed by our speakers
via the email address you provided at
the time of registration
okay let's continue with our questions
two lcms triple quads were mentioned in
your talk
which instrument do you ultimately
recommend for this workflow
i'll take this question in regards to
the instrumentation
we recommend a agilent 6470b
triple quadruple lcms or a 6495c
triple quadruple lcms ultimately
the workflow was designed for
and to hit targets that are achievable
by the 6470b
triple quadrupole however if you wanted
that extra confidence or that extra
sensitivity
you can always use the 6495c
triple quadrupole so so to answer that
question again
directly um the workflow was designed
for the 6470b
but can run on the 6495c
thank you patrick and with this workflow
product what is the cost per sample
yeah i'll take this so uh we have um
a kind of estimated um the use of
consumables uh for
for executing this for the daily one and
it's about
um per um analysis we can say that is
about
0.5 dollars is the cost of analysis
thank you thank you stevie can
laboratories use this workflow solution
as a
validated sop
okay that's a great question yeah um
we are um promising a verified
method and still
customers need to verify or maybe
create an sop as per their
local laboratory need definitely we have
verified it you can
use the methodology and the results
to build your own sop to meet your
laboratory needs
but the short answer is like
the customers needs to
re-verify at their laboratory
using this as a fundamental basic um
results or methods to build their
associate
thank you and what is this special
dynamic
mrm mode and what are its benefits
sure i can take this the dynamic mr
is something that maximizes the
instrument
cycle time for maximum
sensitivity so it's essentially pointing
the
instrument to analyze a specific analyte
at a specific point in time
and the reason why we state that it is
dynamic
is that the user indicates a retention
time
an analyte will elude at
and the instrument will automatically
adjust and account for the overall cycle
time
so if an analyte is not alluding at that
specific time point
the instrument will not acquire
that mrm during that
during that duty cycle so as the analyte
starts to elute you
the instrument points out to only what's
relevant and
this thereby increases the precision and
also the sensitivity as well
thank you patrick and
how is this workflow solution approach
better than the conventional approach
that many labs are doing now
i'll check that yeah so this is like um
um
the workflow solution is like a single
vendor solution which includes
various components to successfully
implement and perform the workflow in a
customer laboratory
this includes um work for i mean
sample preparation the lcms method uh
data analysis procedures and also
recording templates all it's a package
and very importantly even the
consumables also
so um of course you can build it or you
can
develop um a method from scratch but
again as
everyone know that method development is
one of the most
time consuming activity in any
analytical um
situation so this workflow solution
definitely helps a
customer uh to start uh or implement
a workflow solution from the day one and
start analyzing the
samples from the day one because it's
already ready made and
everything is like a single vendor
solution
hope that answers
thank you and we're going to have to
wrap up this final question
can you elaborate more on how to use a
dynamic
mrm database when creating a new method
in the lab
great question thank you yeah so this is
like uh the
gmrm database um uh is includes of
um ms parameters uh like uh the product
ions and the mass
specific parameters for all 210 targets
and
a a customer um can
um can search their preferred
targets from this database using first
keys like
they can search for cast members or they
can or they can
search for um regulatory specific like
eu specific or u.s specific kind of
targets
um so we are also providing a method
which is a kind of
base method and customers can easily
very easily import the relevant
interest targets to this base method
and save into their subset method so
it's very easy and we have uh given all
the instructions
in the in the workflow guide which is
included in this workflow solution
thank you cg and gentlemen thank you
both i'd like to
big thank you to dr patrick patoon and
cg joseph for their time today and for
their important research
and before we go i do want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we have quite a few questions we were
unable to answer today so as a reminder
those questions will be addressed by our
speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through june of 2021
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon
have a great day